look if the plethora of Marvel and DC
films aren't enough to soothe your
superhero cravings you might want to see
what other countries have to offer sure
these movies might not be as technically
impressive as the super-powered
blockbusters we're used to but they
feature enough culture shock quirks to
warrant a watch let's take a trip across
the globe and see the strangest
superhero films released outside the
United States Guardians Russia
if you thought guardians of the galaxy
needed less humor and more super ripped
bears you'll be thrilled - 2017 s
guardians this Russian superhero epic
looks like a knockoff Marvel film with
about a quarter of the budget this
acrobatic fighting insane weapons and
gorgeous people doing battle all the
modern superhero are hallmarks but
Russia really brings the weird with
Ursus the wear bear unlike werewolves
Ursus doesn't have to wait for a full
moon to take bear form he can do it
whenever he wants or if you'd rather
just be a half man half bear there's
that option - which leads to the best
moment of the trailer seeing a man bear
fire off a machine gun the heroic trio
China when it comes to female
superheroes
China has this beat 1992's the heroic
trio is about a squad of three
super-powered women United to stop a
supernatural villain whose main goal is
to find a king for China his kidnapped
18 male babies and one will become the
ruler of the land the others will be
groomed to form an army of killers the
plot may sound a little bit odd but if
you want to see flying motorcycles cut
in half or a leather clad lady riding a
dynamite fuelled barrel your only choice
is the heroic trio three Superman and
mad girl Turkey why settle for one
Superman when you can have three Turkey
has made a lot of knockoff superhero
movies but perhaps the strangest is
1973's three Superman and mad girl three
low-rent Superman knockoffs fight off an
evil foe named mad
for some reason there's also an
old-fashioned definitely made from a
cardboard box robot who plays out heroes
with these death ray will ask Superman
prevail is that actually supposed to be
the devil or just a guy in a mask
watch all 65 minutes to find out zebra
man Japan if you combined Breaking Bad
with kick-ass you'd get 2004 snappin
ease action comedy separate man is about
a failed teacher and family man who
escapes from his depressing life by
secretly dressing up like an unpopular
1970s TV superhero called you guessed it
zebra man but unlike kick-ass the
protagonists of zebra man soon learns he
actually does have superpowers so he
uses them to defeat alien possessed
baddies set on conquering earth
rah won India it looks like some kind of
Indian Iron Man but 2010's raw one is
not a blatant Marvel copy it's more like
a Tron Iron Man mashup a programmer
creates video game with a very powerful
villain named raw one unfortunately the
villain escapes the game and enters the
real world so the game's creator must
transform into a hero named g1 to the
feedom chakra the invincible India did
you know
Marvel legend Stan Lee also created an
Indian superhero chakra the invincible
is Lee's first venture outside the US
and so far the hero has an animated film
for Cartoon Network India and a
live-action version in development the
story is about Raju Rai a young kid who
tries on a blue bodysuit that gives him
spiritually derived superpowers that
turn him into chakra the invincible
protector of Mumbai the return of
Captain invincible Australia the plot of
1983
Australian superhero parody the return
of Captain invincible is unusual to say
the least
alan arkin scap'd in invincible is
America's go-to superhero during World
War two
but during the McCarthy trials he's
ruled a danger to the country and no
longer allowed to fight crime cuts of
the 80s when a villain played by
Christopher Lee gets control of a
Narae that causes people to laugh
uncontrollably the US must find captain
invincible who's now a terrible drunk
hiding out in Australia also it's a
musical mr. and mrs. incredible Hong
Kong 2011's Hong Kong action comedy mr.
and mrs. incredible is about a retired
husband-and-wife crime-fighting duo who
have to deal with the issues of a normal
life are they inspired by The
Incredibles Pixar's 2004 film about a
retired superhero family probably but
the folks at Pixar haven't sued anybody
over it yet maybe their fans
unlike the family favourite the Hong
Kong version partly revolves around the
husband losing interest in sex with his
wife until a new hot lady comes to town
but husband gays a warrior who shoots
lightning from his eyes and wife a Roma
woman who puts men into a trance with
her alluring odor end up rekindling the
spark in the marriage all while
wrangling their giant goldfish Rendell
Finland perhaps the most conventional
film on the list
Finland's Rendall is about Punisher like
figure looking to take down a criminal
organisation that murdered his family
not much is known about the Nordic
nations first masked vigilante but the
trailer for the indiegogo financed flick
jus out in the fall of 2017 hints at a
dark slick dystopian tale with
production values that belie its humble
origin we do know for certain it's the
only superhero movie with official
promotional condoms
huh your move Deadpool - thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love -
you